um Chris you're ugly oh here we go they
straight in everyone's been talking
about it you're just really ugly thanks
beauty is on the inside and inside you
is just
awful it's lucky you're beautiful
because there's nothing up here did you
just call me dumb you went straight to
dumb like woman I was like oh you're
wearing my grandma's sweater and then
you're like you're dumb Chris spends
more time in the hair and makeup chair
than all of it you what are you doing in
there why does it take you we got 20
minutes that is not true cuz I'm waiting
on the set like everybody else like
where the hell is
christh person that's like I don't think
you've ever been on time so not do you
need to watch whatever anyway now we
don't like each other now we're just
airing out all of our problems on